[Music]
[Music]
my name is krishnandu chaudhary aka
krish and i am the author of the book
math and architectures of deep learning
from many publications of new york
and
today i am going to
talk to you
about pca principal component analysis
svd singular value decomposition and
latent semantic analysis lsa so first a
little bit about myself i am currently
the cto and co-founder of drishti
technologies of palo alto silicon valley
california
uh i am glad to let you know that my
company drishti has been recognized by
forbes magazine as one of the top 50 ai
companies of usa before drishti
i was with
google for
like a decade and i have worked in
multiple departments mostly google
research google photos
i actually founded more or less
started the google newspaper search and
also let the google news archive for for
some time other than that i have worked
at adobe systems uh san jose with their
advanced technology group which was
basically the research and also for the
advanced development group
uh for another 10 years so
you can say i have been around which
should be happening from my gray hairs
before we take a deep dive into the
topic of the day i would like to
actually tell you about kind of a
article of belief with me i would say
deep learning and indeed machine
learning is just a form of high
dimensional geometry basically you taken
we represent any input as a an array of
numbers
an array of numbers can be thought of as
a vector
and a vector is essentially a point in a
high dimensional space the number of
dimensions is same as length of the
vector length of the array here is the
crux of it
the
set of interesting points
usually forms a very small cluster a
pattern in that large space all of
machine learning is basically trying to
identify that pattern discern that
pattern in uh
this distribution of points which
corresponds to a distribution of points
let's take a quick example we will see
this examine this in more detail later
but let's say we are trying to
identify images of zebras
now an image is
representable like a vector basically
the vector
elements of the vector would be the
pixel color values so we have a vector
representing an image
now zebras do not have arbitrary color
right they have a very specific color
pattern so the images that contain
zebras would
actually
be a very
well defined
reasonably well defined cluster of
points
in that space of colors
if we can identify if we can
identify that sub space that region
which corresponds to zebras given any
new input array we could tell whether it
belongs to that sub region or not and
based on the answer to that we can say
whether the photo is that of a zebra or
not
this is a very crucial idea it may seem
obvious to some of us but i feel it's
very important to
identify to identify this let us
actually
look at a
toy example
which is represented in this now focus
on
this in the straw example like i said
uh most of real life machine learning
deals with
100 or thousands of dimensions but this
is a special toy example where we are
dealing in only two dimensions
now
let's say the points of interest are
shown by these black dots
these are our zebra zebra images whereas
this two-dimensional plane
is
set of all possible images of this the
zebra images let's say forming this
cluster which looks like a long and
narrow ellipse
how do we identify the pattern here well
the very first thing we note is that the
distribution is such that
the spread of the points
is mostly along this thick line here the
one on which i'm moving my mouse right
now indicated by the thicker
there is some spread there is
some spread variation
along this thinner along the
perpendicular direction but it's
significantly less what that tells us is
that
we can actually
probably represent this entire set of
points
we can replace this with this single
straight line
in other words we can project them the
empty circles the hollow circles
actually represent the projected points
and then we can
essentially replace this cluster of
points with a single line
that
is kind of a pattern recognition we have
identified the entire pattern of zebras
let us say with with that line so we can
say if my point lies near about that my
query point lies near that it's a zebra
what does this really buy for us
well
in some sense this is a little bit like
big picture formation in our heads when
a soccer coach is looking the soccer
coach is looking from outside the
field and the soccer coach is seeing the
whole game
the coach is not seeing very details too
much details but getting a big picture
of the game
a player with the ball is seeing a lot
more detail but is lacking the big
picture consequently it's easier for the
soccer coach to actually analyze the
game better a very similar thing is
happening here we are getting rid of
these small variations which you can
think of as details and we are getting
the big picture that most of the
distribution is along this line
as a result
this simplification
might help us to get a better do a
better analysis of the
points
and of course we have created a more
compact representation which takes less
space that itself is a win
so as a result
this trick which is known as
dimensionality reduction dimensional
reduction because this was a two
dimensional distribution of points for
instance we have reduced it to a single
line which is to say a one dimensional
entity that is why it's called
dimensionality reduction this
facilitates big picture analysis and
also it creates a simpler representation
simpler and more compact and less
expensive representation
so that
in some sense is the core idea behind
principle component analysis we will get
into more details
for the very soon but i just wanted to
leave you with a you know synopsis of
what we are going to do in this session
right at the beginning let's now
try to look at a real life problem
although we will look at a toy version
of a real life problem but it is a real
life problem nonetheless that real life
problem is document retrieval let's say
we have a set of documents in this
little example we have only seven
documents d0 through d6 and each
document is very small a few words
however this is still a valid example
and
the
problem is we will get a new document
and we will have to retrieve
documents from this from our library of
documents
in order of
similarity that is the most similar
document should be ranked first the next
closest document should be ranked second
and so forth
you can easily imagine where this is
very important google for instance would
need to solve this problem constantly
meaning this is their bread and butter
the technique i'm going to discuss right
now is not the only thing google does
it's a simplified version but still this
problem is extremely important for
google what do we do at this stage you
might have realized that the problem
essentially boils down to estimating
similarity of a pair of documents if we
solve that we have solved everything in
this document retrieval so given a pair
of documents we have to come up with a
quantitative way of
scoring their similarity the very first
thing to do is to have a quantitative
representation of the documents itself
this we do with some with a trick called
term frequency
essentially we imagine a very long
vector
this vector's length is same as our
vocabulary's length that is every word
in our vocabulary
has a specific slot
in this vector so if we go by uh
dictionary ordering the first slot may
correspond to aardvark or something and
the last slot will probably correspond
to a word like zymos starting with a z
in the middle we will have all other
words in our dictionary so what we do is
we go into the document for let's say
how many times artwork
appears in this document
zero so we will enter a zero next to
artwork
how many times zymos appears in this
document zero
however we will enter two
next two roses because roses rose
appears twice in this document and so we
will create a vector corresponding to
every document
so
this table
shows
such a factor from those six seven
documents that these you will notice
that roses we have a do and just to
simplify we are kind of pretending that
our vocabulary has only our dictionary
has only four words
i told you this is a toy example then
gun appears one once in document one and
violence appears one you will see a
score of one against each of this and
the word america also appears once and
hence
we have a score of one against america
and so forth so each row is a document
term frequency vector
this is as good as any other way this is
a pretty good way to actually create a
document descriptor vector so to say
one thing to be noted here is we are not
paying attention to
ordering or sequence of words this is a
so-called bag of words model we are just
if a word appears anywhere it cannot
distinguish between words appearing in
one sequence versus another it just
counts the number of occurrences of each
word anyway that's not a bad way may not
be the most sophisticated but not a bad
way to describe a document this bag also
we will work with this term frequency
back of words model now
how
uh
the
geometric view
corresponding to this is shown here
what you will notice is
each word is corresponding to a separate
axis and the number of the coordinate
corresponding to that axis is the number
of occurrences of the word
and this way
we will get a value for each coordinate
and by combining all of them each of
these points
is corresponding to a single document
there is one specific property
deliberately created so
is that
in most of the documents the word gun
and violence appears the same number of
times here their gun once violence once
here gone twice violence twice and so
forth accepting d5 and d6 in d5 only gun
appears in d6 only violence appears keep
this in mind this is going to be
somewhat crucial to understanding what
we are going to say
very soon we have this
geometric representation of the
document vectors the seven document
vectors there are seven points each
corresponding to a separate document
this is the
geometric representation
now how do we measure similarities of
a pair of documents
well each document is a point or in
other words it's a vector there is a
very well-known way of measuring
similarities between a pair of vectors
namely the dot product
so
we can use that that measure is known as
cosine similarity
of course if we just take the dot
product
then
longer documents will have a unfair
advantage they will always
pay two longer document long documents
would always score higher than
very similar but smaller documents we
want to normalize against the document
length that is why we divide the dot
product by the length of the two factors
this is
called cosine similarity we can use this
and
most of the time it works but it has a
very specific blindness
in some sense
the idea of pca evolved to cover that
blindness that is why i am starting with
the simpler technique of cosine
similarity and pointing out where it
fails we will later show how pca
covers that blind spot
in order to understand that
let's go back to our list of documents
if i take the dot product or the cosine
similarity between d1 and d2 i will be
okay
but what watch what happens if i try to
take a cosine similarity between d5 and
d6
the cosine similarity will be zero
because there is no common word that is
a mistake if we examine the entire set
of documents it's quite clear
that the word gun and violence occur
together most of the time
there must be some kind of semantic
similarity that is not visible to cosine
similarity because it's only looking at
common words it's not looking at
secondary relationships like that
this is what pca addresses
so in pca we will very soon see that
that problem is mitigated
you